lost all four games schroeder missed of
course davis was out as well
lebron again on the attack again going
after deandre ayton
and jimmy looks like the lakers have it
by design to get ayton into foul trouble
here
well this is the example of a veteran
team you got two technicals okay
players are upset coaches upset so what
do you do
you attack right back off the dribble
and put the onus on the officials now to
call
fouls in your favor you know young team
may settle for jump shots but you saw
schroeder
pick up a foul going to the basket now
lebron james
does the same team kind of indicating to
the officials you got to make some of
these calls for us now
and devin booker just got hit with a t
see that's what i'm saying
so
[Applause]
again we're kind of at the mercy here
when
they're going off off screen booker's on
his way
looks like to the locker room i don't
think he was ejected
but i don't know
actually i beg you so i'm being told now
both
technical fouls were on booker and he
has been ejected
so man it has been a t-fest here and
booker
is gone that is a huge
swing moment in this game
boy i just you know it's tough to tell
exactly
where it happened i heard the whistle
popped twice jimmy but i didn't see
that they called the tee on them and i
think monty williams still wants
an explanation maybe this is where the
first one comes
i don't know yeah that's